foreign
[Music]
what do you think of Twitter right now
it has the same feeling Vine had before
it went does it kind of yeah I do kind
of feel like it's like a free-for-all
right now this is just a this is burning
down you saw they laid off all their
[ __ ] ad sales team
do you believe that I don't think that
[ __ ] really matters I'm saying like
people are like the media is so [ __ ]
concerned with what is happening at
Twitter they're not they're firing
everyone they're not concerned it's
gonna yeah they are it's all they write
about well it's all they write about
it's like how much Elon is destroying
Twitter but they're not concerned what
do you mean they they just want the you
know they like it that's what I'm saying
it's like why is everyone so obsessed
with it's just a [ __ ] it's Twitter
who gives a [ __ ] no but I'm saying the
media isn't they don't care what happens
to Twitter like they're not concerned oh
no he's ruining it they like this they
like being able to report elon's a bad
guy yeah I know yeah yeah
but it's like anyone that anyone that
like does a takeover of any sort of
company fires 75 of people it's not like
a new story yeah firing the ad team
it makes sense to me oh it's like it's
like they weren't really making money
before yeah I just I don't want ads on
the platforms yeah
get them out of there [ __ ] yeah yeah
random ass [ __ ]
crypto company tweets embed that's
that's
you don't you mean you don't need that
anymore just get it out of there yeah
I will I will pay a hundred dollars a
week for the blue check yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's all I need yeah
I'll pay seven thousand dollars a day
for the blue check for no ads I do think
it's funny when people get legitimate
burns on Elon and they blue check notify
him and and I just know that he wants to
respond to every single one he he does
use the platform way too much yeah I
will say that there's like no possible
way from someone who like used to
actually take tweet writing seriously I
feel like me and you both did yeah as in
like we would constantly think about
like oh that would be a good tweet yeah
whatever curated I feel I know how much
thought it takes
how much time it takes to actually write
I mean I'm not saying my tweets are good
by any means but I'm saying
to generate a following on Twitter let's
just say that yeah because we both did
that yeah it takes a lot of Mind share
it takes a lot of time
the amount he's on Twitter there's no
[ __ ] way that he's like running to
other companies at the same time he's
just playing all these random ass people
yeah this is all today this is all
within an hour yeah yeah up two hours
there we go it's gonna be so funny on it
non-stop right
it's gonna be so funny when his whole
all his companies burn up it's just
because he can't get offline
like he's just so addicted or it could
work like this could like like Twitter
could like Thrive because of all this
stuff you know it's true that is a very
real possibility yeah
which would also be equally as
interesting I think
I think if it died using and also if it
like won it would be interesting
I saw an article about how his boring
company projects have all just ghosted
everywhere really yeah the the tunnel oh
man
I think that's sick though not that I'm
saying those ones like those companies
are cool I think like the thought of La
like having tunnels in La is [ __ ]
awesome well there's this thing called
the subway
I don't think we have that here do we we
do a Subway yeah that goes where with
the Hollywood
an underground Subway yeah what yes I
know
have you taken it no no this where does
it go they're building a line that goes
through like South La that will
eventually connect to LAX and I think
the goal is to get it to spit out near
the Sofi Stadium
and then they're building one all
through Culver City damn that's sick
that one's above ground though yeah
but the one through Culver goes to the
beach nice
[Music]
um
but yeah yeah I've taken that one
actually I've taken the Santa Monica one
yeah that goes out to uh whatever
Stadium I never knew this there's a
company Nicola yeah they made cars I
never knew about that downhill it's a
scam uh yeah but I never knew that about
that specific commercial where they ran
the truck down ahead it was fake yeah
yeah
so funny
fascinating fascinating and the whole
the whole the person who exposed it was
basically this guy that runs this hedge
fund that [ __ ] loser
who the guy that exposed it yeah what a
nerd
I think it's cool it's like he he's like
a short seller so he basically is like
just like just like a a chronic hater
his shorts companies and then he like
does major researcher you know vice
versa does research first figures out
what's com which companies are like
basically giant scams short sells them
and then exposes them
and that was one of the ones yeah
he buys like options against yeah yeah
he just shorts the stock yeah so this is
a company Nikola like like they went
public before they just went public
based on like this one video right like
yeah back when there was like five other
electric car companies that all went
public without actual products because
of how popular Tesla was
these were this was one of them they
named themselves Nikola which is like
come on
and then they promised this like yeah
this like electric semi truck
and it was driving in the video but
really they just filmed it going down a
hill and they tilted the they tilted the
video so it looked like it was going
straight yeah they like they went public
raised a [ __ ] ton of money
um and I think the guy who was running
it it's like not
it's weird though it's like not a crime
like I don't think the guy
I don't think you can get like
charged for doing that genius what's
what's the market cap now of Nikola no
way
these this is everyone holding Dogecoin
right here holding the what was there
what oh my God 65 what was the stock
price bro 65 right after the IPO yeah so
like their market cap must have been
what like 60 billion or whatever 120
billion oh my God buddy made a killing
on that
they they're they had some Revenue
second quarter this year 18 mil
revenue on what
I don't know so maybe it's not a
complete scam but that's so wild bro
yeah
they still are a thing yeah
the Rev let's see about this rev truck
dude oh yeah bro
let's buy one
let's be the only ones to own one
dude come on they got TurnKey solutions
for this we should do we should build
like a mobile
that should be the next
thing we buy mobile Studio no I just
like yeah like uh like we that should be
it right and then we're cruising just on
the road yeah wherever we want to go
yeah
just Highway cruising oh dude we should
uh we should just buy a private jet but
it's for podcast yeah exactly yeah
and that was a podcast Studio yeah
yeah it's just one big work expense
we should get a electric semi truck
combined with a [ __ ] private jet yeah
and a helicopter yeah
does it all